this past weekend let's get into some
activity on
you
[Applause]
[Music]
never blame me
Monday July 10
[Music]
Monday
self
moves up guys it is July 10th and I am
happy you know the usual man I'm here
and I'm happy to be with you I just got
back from Nashville Nashville Tennessee
and man first I've never seen a place
that had so many cranes so much
construction construction building I
mean they were building everything's
being built
you couldn't find probably a spare stick
or thing of glue in the city everything
they're stacking building cranes up
lifts you know Latinos people yelling or
delay send up another brick send up
another brick man well you know a lot of
core a lot of ah contractors out there
you know hey I'm a contractor you know
I've got all I've got a tool belt and
I've got some mum I've got a hammer you
know and I just my hammer this was my
daddy's hammer there's a sixth
generation hammer look at the net look
at all the oh look at my initials I'm uh
I'm Wyatt Dunhill the 9th and we all
been having this hammer in our family
this is a family hammer a lot of
construction in Nashua man blew my mind
you know because I actually thought
about trying to get into that market you
know tap into their buying something
rent something just be involved you know
in uh
in a while back in now I believe now
it's too late to get in there's just so
but so it's so bigger so I've never been
to a city that so much being built you
know just really big over there in
Nashville we had a great time out at
Zanies man we took a ride we took a ride
on that stage man was my first time
being there I want to thank everybody
that came out I mean we had um we had
some rambling Ricky some rambling
Ricky's from Arkansas that drove five
hours we had some uh some trippy vixens
from Mississippi you know some cute
scoop seas you know running that trim
out there
you know we had a people from Atlanta
Chattanooga the noog we had people
coming out and enjoying it and enjoying
the show we had a great time and I want
to thank Janie's and I want to thank
everybody in Nashville that came out and
enjoyed it you know went out with some
friends I had some friends hadn't seen
in a while one of my buddies had a girl
that he knew met it met it medicine the
show or whatever and he ended up not
being able to make it into the end so
his girl was there I mean she got drunk
shoes in the front row and you know does
sometimes is these women at the kinda
shows and it's usually honestly it's
women and it's Disick it's usually an
attractive woman or woman who thinks
that she's attractive who has always
been told she's attractive or you know
kind of spoiled let's just say spoiled
because you can look anyway and be
sported and just really ruins a lot of
the show and that happened Saturday
night man this girl wouldn't he shan't
the full gobo you know like dang dude
you know if I had a bag of
shut-the-fuck-up feathers oughta
probably just uh hit this young lady
with him this lady would not I mean she
just she had to be the center of
attention and it's really when somebody
does that it doesn't happen a lot but
it's just there's such a selfish move
you know I'm up there trying to give it
my all they're people that have come to
see this I've come to do this and you
got these selfish just damn pigeons dude
a bunch of [ __ ] honestly coke pigeons
probably because this girl looked like
she'd been just you know beacon around a
bit you know huffing for a little bit of
that dust you know trying to cop a gram
up through the bottom of her beak and so
just made me mad man my buddy I didn't
get to tell him and here's what I
couldn't decide was because my buddy he
didn't get there to the end of the
search so he didn't know this girl and
she didn't ruin the show now I'm a
professional I could have thrown her out
at some point if I wanted to she was but
if I'd have been going another
minutes onstage I woulda tossed her but
she did just she did enough where it was
like she definitely impaired the show
you know when you have to tell somebody
a couple times to get their act together
and they're an adult that's unfortunate
you know it's unfortunate but anyhow man
now I just Candice how do I tell my
friend because it's the next day July
tell him look man you know you know
these beautiful birdies you sent out you
know they were just you know chirping up
the little Armageddon that was wrecking
everything or do I not say anything
because if I don't say anything I just
let it pass and it's gone there's
nothing there's nothing there you know
in sometimes you have to make that
choice and sometimes I'm bad at making
that choice figuring out what to do you
know because at a certain age at a
certain point your life and it can be
any age if you're smart you realize it
just if I bring something up again then
it's up again if I let it be then it's
gone but then it could happen again and
it just man it just burns my dick skin
when somebody behaves that entitled you
know you can just tell that somebody
hadn't been told no you know when you
see up with a lot of these pretty girls
I'll be honest with you they haven't
been told no they haven't told no
because we live in a society that caters
that rib makes it easier if you it meant
if you are beautiful you're symmetrical
looking come on let's be honest dude
let's just be honest
let's just be real anyhow we got there
we did it we had a good time and I want
to thank everybody that came out man
what's going on with me I got in and I
got into Nashville and I went to had me
some barbecue and if you know me or you
ever seen me I like to find a meat plate
when I'm in town you know I'm no
stranger to a meat and you could find me
usually lurking around some type of pork
or beef or a brisket and I'm going
stranger to that activity you know a a
salts or some sort of a piquant or you
know honey
give some you know a Motown just a just
something something like condiment you
know something and that's something that
I like and I find that place and I find
me a meat you know I was in Tampa
Florida night barbecue five days in a
row from a shitty establishment I'll say
that so you know if a man's eating
shitty barbecue five days in a row you
know he will [ __ ] turn his skin
inside-out to show up and what he'll do
the damage he'll do at a decent
establishment and that's me that's me
around a meat so if you ever want to
trap me if somebody out there is
thinking about trapping me or murdering
me because I know they got murderers out
there you know I've been a longtime fan
of murder shows and of actual murder I
don't I don't condone murder and I don't
want murder for anybody I've never laid
in bed at night wishing for murder but I
have I do get excited with a new episode
of Dateline and sometimes I will
honestly every time a new season comes
out I will pray that that you know pray
for the people in the episodes that are
gone but I'll also pray that if more
people get murdered in the future that
they don't find their killers just yet
because I want another season man and
maybe that's selfish I don't know what
that means about me but I know I'm not
the only one because murder is probably
the most popular genre of entertainment
on television you know we've come to
love murder not not who's there
hopefully Lester Holt you know hopefully
Tamron Hall there's a Dateline host from
Dateline but yeah people love a murder
man hopefully Robert Stack unsolved
mysteries I'm John Walsh on Walsh but
I've always been um you know I've always
been a fan of the missing and the
murdered than that and anyhow was I
telling you guys if you ever want to
trap me somewhere the meat or the the
the ruse to use
is meat you know if I'm walking on the
street and I see a plate on the ground
and it looks unhampered with and they
got a bunch of you know some freshly
stacked meats on there boy
face-first son you never seen a dude
dive face-first arms by his side not in
front of him into a meat plate and
that's just how I get sometimes I don't
think a lot of that's growing up I grew
up in around cereal
a lot of grains you know you'd see
occasional meat you see um you know they
had a lot of people doing Bologna in our
neighborhood baloney slices they had a
lot of not a lot but that a couple
brothers around us always grilling up
dove and um you know air game and small
air game and usually a legal air game I
had family that had owl for Thanksgiving
that was actually this past year two
owls actually which is an overrated bird
and I will argue with that to the death
with anybody but but yeah we had a but
if you ever want to trap me meat is the
way and so I'm probably shouldn't giving
that clue out there but it is but yeah
man a lot of construction sites in
Nashville and that made me think if
you're going to murder and this goes out
so I guess anybody that and if you have
ever killed anybody man and you want to
confess it you can hit that hotline boy
that number is nine eight five six six
five nine four zero three
I believe yep nine eighty five six six
four nine five zero three and we're
going to get to some calls in this few
minutes got some great calls this week
but but yeah if you hit the construction
sites great place to get rid of a body
you know that's body country I mean and
I've often wanted to go look for bodies
and stuff at night but a lot of the
sites were secure but anyhow man
Nashville is definitely a great place to
hide a body this time of year and a lot
of a lot of real estate going up but one
one thing that gets when you see these
buildings going up and all this
construction and activity you see I
start to get I start to get it makes me
a little mad
because now Real Estate's become such a
business that you know they just move in
and they know how many square feet like
these contractors and these big
developers it's all it's just you know
it's the same property they have here
that they have in Minneapolis so that
they have in Huntsville or that they
that they have in Houston or Chicago or
Champaign Urbana it's like it's just it
becomes so formulaic you know and that's
one thing that's happened with real
estate over the years is just become
very it's becoming for you know just
such a formula out there like everything
else you know I guess it's just part of
the you know the cookie cutter future
that we're really just rippling towards
here it seems like a lot of times yeah
so that was it man that was Nashville I
had a great time and I want to thank
everybody that came out we had a great
time and I hope that as a knees has me
back I want to thank my friend Richard
who called in there a bunch I want to
thank my boy Mike and him and came in
from Arkansas and and I want to thank
Lucy over at Zanies and everybody at
Nash everybody as Amy's in Nashville
this coming week I'll be in Orlando this
weekend I'm in Orlando you can check
that out also if you're on the YouTube
right now you can see right behind me
first let me tell you is Orlando dates
the 13th through the 16th of July then
on the 20th of July I'm in San Diego the
27th through the 30th of July I'm in
Montreal it's just for Laughs comedy
festival August 10 through 13 i'm in
addison texas and september 7 6th
through 9th I'm in Austin Texas
so there we go man those are the dates
coming up and if you're on YouTube you
can see right behind me we got a
beautiful beautiful print that you can
order online
it's from the ham panini Zee soundtrack
it's from that album and it says keeping
my squad hydrated and they got a
gentleman juicing up a couple of hams
that he's got in this coat you can get
on YouTube and check that out and you
can find that as well as my other albums
and some other our pieces of
paraphernalia at Theo von comm slash
store I'm having some coffee I got a
comment I got a set sign at the Comedy
Store world-famous Comedy Store I'm
excited
when I see some of my dogs up there I
need to see I'd love to see Bert
Kreischer up there fighter in the kid
those gents
you know rogue and he's always been in
been up there so much recently it's just
been inspiring so to be around some of
those guys that's been great all right
man what can we get into right now kind
of think about something great I want to
tell you guys about you know I want to
share kind of a story or something maybe
from growing up that I haven't told you
yet but let's get to a coal man we got a
call right here and usually we get calls
from adults but everybody's welcome here
because here's the thing we were all
children once and sometimes I wish it
were easier to access those feelings and
those thoughts and memories that I had
as a child because what's interesting as
a child is all your memories and all
your thoughts everything is so real and
it's so fresh you know what the first
time you do something the first time you
see it's like that that's the first time
so it's so thick but for some reason as
I gotten older it's harder to access
some of that and it makes me upset a lot
of times you know and I don't know if I
need to you know I don't want to get all
of them with these psychics or
hypnotists I used to see a hypnotist for
a while and it said lady was a lady was
nuts it was full of [ __ ] she was really
just kind of like a lullaby esteem to
sleep and then wake me up and I don't
150 bucks man you know it's like a
hooker but without the cozy ya feel me
all right man let's take this first call
right here I see oh this is Preston and
I am from Petaluma California my mom
loves you she lets me listen to you when
we're always in the car but okay this is
Preston from Petaluma this Petaluma
Preston and it sound like a child to me
there's sound like a child or one of
those people on on The Learning Channel
that have I think it is called civil
dysmorphia or something where you are
very small you know just a tiny friend
but
let's hear em out thank you for calling
Preston and thank you for your mother
for letting you listen to others past
weekend only for my advice I have this
cross and I don't know how to tell her
about my feelings for her like she's the
one for me man my heart just goes insane
when I'm around her so there was one day
now I think was the last day I could see
her she didn't die but I think that was
a lot of day and cleaner because I
haven't been seeing her around and I
just need some advice when it
okay so we got Preston his colon he's
has a crush this young lady I'm assuming
or maybe a man but he said her so it's a
probably a female you know uh but you
know some of the vagina gender and he is
it had feelings for her and doesn't out
of share his feelings and he wants to
know how to share his feelings when he
sees her again let's hear about her one
time to say something like what I should
say to her I tell her about my feelings
and how much I care about her and how
she's my soul mate
I need some advice about that and have a
good day Co hope I'm on the podcast bye
Wow so his mom's a fan and maybe she put
him up to it
to sneak in here but you know you get
you hear a child's voice it makes you
feel does it make me feel it's funny
because I play adults voice adults :
here a lot
hit the hotline but we hadn't had a
child hit it and it makes me it's
interesting it make me feel something
made me feel that it well first of all I
kind of took me back I guess to a time
when I was a child
you're more intrigued because you wonder
you know how this child really got
involved hit the hotline and also it
makes me think it makes me want to it
makes it makes me feel young again I
guess that's what the feeling is
of you know I put this call first you
know get three or four calls I'll put
this call first because I guess yeah
that was it
you know it's added that desire to want
to be young again but what do you do for
a soul for your soul mate first of all
your soul only sounds like it's about
twelve years old
Preston and while that's a beautiful
soul man that's a beautiful soul you
know you don't have to man you know what
you got to tell her how you feel bro
because here's the here's you don't
here's what I hope here's what here's
why I went wrong I was your age once at
12 or 11 you know and I was I was in
love with this girl by me and she had a
badly chipped tooth she was I mean she
might have been born with her whole I
mean everything and sure she was just a
chipped girl her whole everything about
it was a little chip she had kind of a
little divot in her chin and maybe
coming in you know kind of it was a
invert in one of the temples a bit and
she was just chipped up you know like
she'd come out the birth canal but it
wasn't a uh you know it kind of rimmed
it bang her on the rim a little she had
banged around the rim a little but um
and I should have told her how I felt
man I should have told her how I felt
cuz I loved her I was a kid you know the
kid but I was just I loved her you know
she lived by me and I'd almost told her
one day but somebody shot her shot a dog
somebody shot a rabid dog just like
literally the moment I was going over to
talk to her somebody shot a rabid dog
and but anyhow Preston you got to tell
her because here's what I did and I
don't know how old you are but I ended
up I would end up I would pretend she
was a pillow I had a pillow they had a
white case one time that I got four for
Halloween and I didn't use it because I
didn't want to be a ghost and a bunch of
just [ __ ] because every you know it was
it was like a vampire year and ghosts
were out and blah blah blah but I wrote
I rented up just writing this girl's
name on the pillow and I would just kind
of you know hug the pillow at night know
what kind of grown
in my body up against it and I did that
instead of choosing to go speak to her
so you got to find a way to talk to her
man
you know and I would do something make
it simple first of all you just need to
you sound like a creative guy you know
maybe you could take a little note and
write it in a balloon or something and
and you know give it to her and you know
maybe pop it a little bit to get her
feelings on the edge and then hit her
with that note when you got our feelings
on edge you might be able to sneak your
feelings into her feelings you know what
I'm saying you could also you know maybe
you write a message in the dirt or
something with a stick you know here's a
move that I would that I would that I
did when I got older but I could have
done when I was younger you know once
you're in a conversation whether you
could say hey I have something for you
close your eyes right and this is kind
of a lame dudes move I used to use this
I think and I'm just saying it's lame in
case you guys think it's lame and then
and so I've kind of covered my tracks
but I would say I have something for you
put out your hand and then she would
close your eyes and then I drop a little
bit of lip action on her hit her with
them lips you know because the kiss says
a million words that's what they say
dude a kiss I think a kiss says a
million words Preston so I would I
dropped them lips on her man
you know I'd hit her with them soft red
hammers dude I'd hit her with them soft
red hammers and uh but in the meantime
make sure that if she says no how are
you going to recover from that how are
you going to behave after have a back-up
plan for what to say because that's when
it gets weird for a guy when he puts all
his marbles you know in that in the end
his gun and then he shoots them all
right out a woman and then he's left
standing there and she wants to hear
something because she's rejected him and
he don't have any marbles left so save a
marble man but good luck out there fire
him off some other poor choices I made I
was in love with a girl in junior high
school instead of telling her I sat in
class the entire class and built-up
saliva in my mouth
and then I spit into her hair after
class um because I don't know why
something's wrong with me you know I
just couldn't I just didn't know how to
express my feelings or talk to women I
guess and I thought somehow in my head I
thought that was going to let her know
how much I cared and I ended up getting
suspended so don't do that man I've made
other poor choices over the years as
well but we'll get into those once you
call back when you're 18 but thanks for
calling press and you know and good luck
out there but I say you give it a shot
because you don't want to be sitting
here at 37 and not know how to express
your feelings so I'd be clear on exactly
what you're feeling you said soul mate
but soul mate is it's a little bit
manufactured it's a little bit of a word
that's just out there that's sometimes
it doesn't feel as real as it could I
get more specific would you exactly care
about about her you know
what makes you like her so that if she
says no at least you still got some
friendship you want to at least be able
to end with friendship you know because
then that can turn it that can turn up
later you know you still got a lot of
time ahead of you but did I like your
enthusiasm and tell your mother I said
hey she sounds she sounds cute honestly
all right let's move into another call
here dude now on the last podcast we
talked a lot about America we have some
gentleman call I got one right here
let's hit it
hey Theo what's up this is Alex I'm
Chucky and I just this is Alex from
Kentucky
Thank You Alex let's hear it talk about
poor people being lazy licensed episodes
talk about that let's talk about poor
people being lazy the poor and lazy
popular subculture in America let's hear
it and I come from a town of about 1400
people a small town everybody knows
everybody lays a kid to half of them and
my mama raised me on food stamps
my dad worked regular factor job you
know we made made ends meet everybody my
family got hooked on drugs
raising cousins you know do it doing
what doing what they do okay so uh just
two Alexes from Kentucky came up in a
poor family mother worked father worked
on some some government assistance but
they made ends meet and thank you for
calling analysis as far as being lazy
and coming out of the fourth place like
that I don't think that that it
automatically makes you lazy kind of
think it's hard to rise out of that but
if you use that at the fire or fuel to
propel you farther you can actually get
places you know you're right man I'm
glad you called about this you know
because last week I was taught our first
day we did an episode about America and
people calling what they thought America
was and and a lot of my views really
came out of this small town experience
that I had the weekend before a lot of
my thoughts but but there's a it's just
such a bigger conversation about America
and what it means to be American but
yeah this is a serious thing man you
know because the poor white the poor
white in this country are just I think
have been tossed to the side you know
they think if you're poor they think L
poor whites are rednecks which is so not
true
most poor white people are just poor and
white the percentage are actual rednecks
I bet it's very small and people don't
realize how hard it is to come out of
poverty if no matter what color you are
you know and it's crazy because in
America that's almost like a right a
right to the right to rise from poverty
it's almost like reserved these days for
minorities and it's like if you're white
you weren't allowed to that wasn't
allowed to be your story this is things
that I felt you know Alex is hard to
make this about me but you just got me
thinking about these things because I
can relate to a lot of that you know I
can relate to having a family member
work
and that and you're right laziness
doesn't have to be it can inspire you
you know it can really inspire you and I
think I think if you're able to be aware
enough and you know if your parents are
able to at least show you enough light
where you can see the other side of
things and it sounds like somebody in
your family influenced you enough you
had to have a positive enough influence
and I think a lot of that's where that's
where you see people go one way or the
other
where they fall into the trap of being
lazy or they fall into the the ease of
being lazy I mean you mention your whole
family getting addicted drugs yeah
that's easy it's easy to get addicted to
drugs man you know because when you're
running around in you're poor and you
there's no rehab there is no when you
got money and go to a rehab you know you
can go live with an aunt or an uncle in
a different place there's just other
outlets to get you out of it you know
you can have a family member that can
call the local sheriff and get you off
the hook for a when you got money you
can do all those things when you rapport
there's just a lot that stacked against
you I don't care what color you are and
I appreciate you sharing that man
there's a lot that's stacked against you
and we get you know being poor and white
in America we get we get just picked on
you know because we get brunt we get
thrown in with just white America that
used to you know the British and the
wealthy Americans they used to run the
country and owned slaves and all this
[ __ ] I doubt you know like I don't think
that was a lot of the poor you know and
I just feel like yeah there's just a lot
there man there's a lot where you get
stuck when you're poor and white dude
nobody it feels like nobody gives a [ __ ]
and I remember growing upon that time of
M&M and thank God from an M that dude
probably in spot any person who's
probably about 35 had to be and grew up
poor poor and white probably was
relevant by our by mmm but I appreciate
you calling man keeping post I don't
know how things are going if you don't
mind Alex I saw you call from Beaty's
Ville betty's Ville I think that's what
it's called is a man that places had a
lot of poverty over the years and
there's a
book you should read as well I'm going
to recommend to you called hillbilly
elegy I'm reading it right now and it's
it's it's amazing man it's just it's
about your culture and the things that
happened in your area in Kentucky and
you'll love it man it sounds like you
you sound like you could be a character
in the book but thanks for calling Alex
appreciate it man appreciate you just
helping helping us think about that and
good luck to you and your family let's
hit another call here a field this is
Anthony out of Salt Lake City Utah just
listening to a podcast of yours right
now on what it feels to be an American
thanks for calling Anthony together some
american of lumo on the american side of
things sweet Anthony I come from the
Spanish background with family Spanish
and uh they're proud to be Mexican
Spanish and Mexican homework you know
what I I whenever someone asked me what
my heritage is it is always American I
am a die-hard American I love my country
more than Bruce Willis reference onward
than any other country in the world I
would do anything for my country my
biggest regret in the world is not
joining the military to fight for my
country I have a lot of family that's in
the military and I'm I'm extremely proud
to call to live here there's nothing
that pisses me off more than seeing
these [ __ ] [ __ ] that want to stomp
on the flag walk whoo Anthony hitting
him high notes hitting them vulgar
hunters you could see him escalate there
let's keep it going thank you for
calling Anthony on the flag talk [ __ ] on
this country do you know what if you
don't [ __ ] like it here get the [ __ ]
out plain and simple this is the
greatest country in the world for many
reasons and it's not on the backbone of
those [ __ ] my generation of 27 my
generation is absolutely [ __ ]
spineless man I'm tired of it
I just everyone needs to get back into
the would do anything for their country
would love to do anything for the cut
for their country well I'm going to stop
you right there and I appreciate you
calling but now when you when we start
to say that everybody needs to do
something everybody needs to do this or
everybody needs to do that or everybody
should that's where we got to check
ourselves because I feel you I feel you
man you're not say you're angry you know
people are angry for tons of reasons
from all different perspectives all
different angles people have a lot of
anger right now but once we start
thinking that other people should do
stuff or everyone should that's where we
start screwing up because that's never
going to happen
you know it's rarely gonna happen unless
there's a huge unless there's a you know
a huge natural disaster or there's a war
or something that makes people realize
it takes us out of our comfort zone then
then there's not it's going to be tough
really to unify us at this point I feel
because people are very divided people
come from just such different worlds
that they are not seeing the same thing
that's the biggest truth is that people
are just are seeing things differently
you know if you grow up in one place or
you your reality is just it's not the
same reality as it isn't a lot of times
in another place and my place also mean
socioeconomic status but let's keep
hearing you out Anthony
appreciate calling us sharing your all
your angst until we can get back into
that time you know this country is hurt
it's hurt you go Anthony feels like it's
hurt man it's interesting it's
interesting you know and it's one of the
things last people last week people are
out we're saying was that you can think
anything you want here you know and it's
weird to say that sometimes we should
shut America down you know shut the
borders and this and that because our
families got here you know it's like do
just keep handing out food or if people
are still still come showing up to eat
or at some point you just say we got a
we got them hold food for the people are
already here just for tomorrow you know
there's a lot of there's a lot there man
there's a lot there you know but I do
believe that I don't think it's fair
that there are people in America who
aren't citizens and who aren't accounted
for and because that's just scary to me
and I don't know how you figure that out
comfortably though I don't know how you
do maybe at some time I'll have an idea
you know as I learn more but at the
present moment I don't but I appreciate
you you calling and sharing your angst
there bro a lotta angst out there in the
world dirty aunt popping off with a
little angst you know and and also
diversity is a big thing like in some
cut like my song my reference was coming
last week on this past weekend from just
I was in a small town it was mostly
white mostly white you know and the town
I grew up in was black and white so I
don't but I don't even know what it's
really like to be in a lot of these
other ethnicities and other cultures be
around them I did live in Tucson Arizona
for a while and I just I went to high
school with a lot of Latinos made ganas
you know so I guess I did get some
understanding there but it's different
man when you are I can where your
families you know here illegally you
know you're hiding from worse
circumstances in another country you've
run from those you know I'm sure that
your view of America is different but I
hope that it's good I hope that you know
I do hope that it's that it's one where
you put America first because that
really that irks me when people do not
you know when I'll and I'll recite this
story I had somebody at the show this
weekend remind me of it the first Latino
boy I ever met now when I was in eighth
grade I was in mr. Blackwell's class
Christopher Blackwell and he was
teacher mine at William pitcher
University no you William pitcher junior
high school sorry
somebody said it was a university one
time and it wasn't and that was me just
now but this saw but this school it was
pretty it was pretty separate on the
playground they had the hick tree for
Hix and those are people that you know a
rednecks basically the Hicks and then
they had the prep tree which is like
prep your kids and then they had the
black they didn't really have a black
tree the black kids just kind of went
wherever they wanted you know black it's
kind of ruled the roost a little bit and
because like his views of the toughest
they were the toughest kids you know
actually that's some of them they hit
kids were pretty tough so you didn't see
much squaring off between them that much
but um but anyway that's the school
that's where the school was kind of set
up a little bit a little bit segment not
segregated on purposes people chose to
hang out in those spaces chose to this
was all choice it wasn't like don't you
know you're no one's allowed over here
those are just kind of like the hangout
benches and uh and I remember I had we
had a Mexican kid that came named
Nicolas Nicolas and the first day in
class man he everybody was like holy
smokes dude there's a real Mexican here
people were fired up and people were I
remember the set the next day like
people were wearing like vasant's [ __ ]
and um one boy could drive and he played
like mariachi music in his car on a tape
some boy drew a mustache on his like
above his lip with a black marker like
people were fired up into what to do you
know we didn't know anything about
really a lot about Mexicans because they
just didn't have them didn't have them
around and most of us you're not
learning about something unless there's
a reference to it near you you're not
and in any way Nicolas was there and he
seemed like he knew everything you know
and just like look older and he had like
and he was in our science class where we
learned sexual education and the crazy
thing about the sex ed class was I
remember the class of the biology class
and they had all these animal cages
around the room and at the beginning of
class you could go in there and hold on
to an animal can you could reach into
the cage and just get an animal
different types small ground game hams
G pigs you know there's that poster
right behind me boy keeping my squat
hydrated but you could get those a snake
a bunny you know some other small things
dirty stuff nutria maybe pigeon maybe
baby pigeons and you could hold them
with you during class you know you're
supposed to put them back in the
beginning but a lot of people would hold
them and I remember this was around the
time when a lot of boys especially
during that sex ed time we're getting
erections and so a lot of boys would
have those sweatshirts or would have
those hand places where you can put your
hands in the front you know the hand
warmer and they put that animal in there
and that rumbling of that animal that
animal activity during the class and
talking about the sex ed mr. Blackwell
talked about the sex education and
seeing that you know the drawings of the
ovaries and all that the boys would get
excited and you were much more likely to
get spry really or to get you know jump
sprung you know where to get really you
know tip hip if you will if you had an
animal in there which you kind of you
know keeping you motivated keeping your
body motivated so that was just a
popular thing about happened but anyway
Nicholas came into this class and the
first day he's in there we're talking
about sexual education and every kid in
there his cheeks are red and people are
just having million questions but afraid
to ask them and he raises his hand and
he's like hey mr. blackwell and this is
an impersonation of him I'm not making
fun of him this is how he sounded I
don't care that he sounded Mexican I
want you to have an accurate idea
he's like hey mr. Blackwell what is pop
that cherry mean Holmes and the place
went nuts dude I mean we were you know
viva la Mako you know like we everybody
all of a sudden was Mexican it was a
common stance intent intent Anna you
know odelay
Valenzuela was our dad's name Richie
you know Oh Donna and everybody was just
fine I mean it was just nobody ever just
had the balls you know that got me to
ask something like that to mr. Blackwell
and so we were fired up dude we had a
new Mexican friend and he was asking
questions about a sexual you know and
and then after that everybody was like
what is Bob that Jeremy Oh
who the [ __ ] that Jeremy home people
were dancing everybody the black kids
were all fired up you know what no
Jeremy oh what a hook the chair in me
huh and um and people were fired up well
anyway all that ego went to Nikolas his
head man to his cabeza pretty quick and
he'd been saying at the end of school
idea that he was a rapper you know
because that was like the coolest thing
to be at the time if you were a rapper
you know in the universe really and it
still kind of is a little bit you know
but at the time that was a cool thing to
be a rapper and he told us all of a
sudden that usually just blurted out
their clashing I'm a rapper and it was
like what this dude is a rapper you know
this guy's a Mexican rapper you know who
knows about Buffett Jerry you know and
the next day Nicholas came to school
people are fired up everybody's you know
couple of people drawn on moustaches now
you know people are keyed up you know
and people are saying that Mexican
girlfriends and like different Sid local
towns now and stuff like a lot of Latino
rumors are starting to fly nicholas
shows up and he's got a shirt on and it
says nicolas he had written it with
marker marks a lot
it said Nicholas the rapper on the shirt
right but he misspelled rapper
one P and I don't know if that's the
exchange rate on rapper but in America
that's illegal and it said Nicholas the
raper and and they then you do not
that's not something to play with you
know you don't play around with rape
ideas and stuff and and that day they
threw him out of school they expelled
him and that was uh we just had a day
and a half of Mexican a day and a half
of Latino culture and God bless them man
wherever you're at out there I'm going
to say this to you Nicolas Nicolas if
for Nick meet help wherever you are
thank you man thank you for coming there
and just because after you left
everybody started asking questions about
sex man and we missed you dude and
people referenced you I remember they
had a Halloween party people wore shirts
I said Nicholas the raper on them and
for years people said it and and just
peace be with you and God be with you
man wherever you are and be well brother
and I hope to see you soon man hope to
see you soon and that day no animals
that day I remember it was a weird day
just everything was we had a little bit
of a hangover from all of that but but
that's uh that's the story of Nick the
raper onward all right let's take
another call what do we have here here
what's up buddy this is a pet from
Mobile Alabama Pat from Mobile thank you
for calling
first of all just a good word about the
haircut man um don't know if you're oh I
remember this is Patrick with that uh
fifty thousand dollar appendage now we
had an episode a while back you can find
it on YouTube about the appendage where
Patrick had we had people calling that
were missing limbs the missing someone
was missing a leg somebody's missing at
it I think actually in Nepal but Tom but
Patrick called in and thank you for
calling back man and you know what dude
for a guy who's the you know is okay
with the impaired you really got some
issues with this hair don't you you know
and I think a hair look I know it's bad
brother
barber is working with Isis I'm not sure
if he's having all the
or let's run it back real quick here
what's up buddy this is a pet from
Mobile Alabama
first of all just uh still worried about
that haircut man um don't know if your
barber is working with Isis I'm not sure
if he's having a holy war with your hair
or what all is going on with your barber
in you
I got no idea what's going on well I'll
tell you what's going on man I'm not
growing this okay God grows my hair dude
I'm not here sharecropping Patrick you
know and it takes some it takes a mess
when you walk into a place I know this
is the worst haircut okay I know it
brother
and there's something when you walk into
a place with the worst haircut you are
the underdog you were the underdog
immediately it sets the table in the
room Patrick that I'm the underdog and
watch what I do when I got this dirty
cut watch me shine because anybody can
walk in there with the fancy hair you
know with the gelatin and the slick nur
in it but you walk in they're coming in
natural you know with just gravity
pulling on the back of your reins and
you come in there and you shine and that
shows them while I should not a judge
that man but I do appreciate you asking
about it man look here a little bit more
what's your what your what your call
today about pets but uh I got a friend
who's getting locked up
and he's gonna do some time anyway I
told to watch out for bootie goons and
he wasn't familiar with bootie goons I'm
like well these are men who are
basically mercenaries for the dudes who
run the block you know yeah secondary
[ __ ] they call them secondary
[ __ ] and uh in like um you know
white-collar prisons and stuff like that
it's like if you don't want well armored
so like if you owe me money and you
didn't pay I'm gonna send the booty goon
to come check you out now do I know
you're aware and familiar with all the
dark arts um I wonder if you could maybe
give my buddy some advice or maybe how
to avoid bootie goons well I mean if
he's in prison and he's new there you
know I've never done time you know I've
never done time I spent a night in jail
in Natchez Mississippi then uh what else
I got locked in a cage once for about a
day and a half but but I will say this
man bootie goon that's somebody from
what I've heard is when you know say
there's a man in prison and he's new and
the other guys want to show him who's
boss they want some who runs the roost
they will send a man over there who
likes doing sex with other men and they
will make that man have sex with the
other man with the new guy like your
buddy so they'll send over a booty goon
but it's not like you think it's not the
guy he's coming to like pin your buddy
down and bang him this dude holds your
buddy down somehow gets him erect and
then pop dropping locking on that behind
you know and he shines him up with that
brown-eyed girl you feel me
and he basically he kind of molest your
buddy I want to say rape somebody he may
do that to your buddy with his buh buh
buh buh buh buh behold so he hit him
with that brown-eyed girl you know what
I'm saying that Rue McClanahan they used
to call it that Rue McClanahan and
brown-eyed girl and if you know that
that was a song about butt sex you know
hey where did we go days when the rains
came down in the hollow playing a new
game you know what I'm saying down in
the hollow playing a new game my brown
eyed girl but yeah man for avoiding
bootie goons
dude one thing you could do bro I mean I
thought honestly about just your buddy
could get rid of his genitalia
and that sound may sound crazy to some
people like Odile you're nuts well I
have nuts but how much easier would I be
if I didn't how much more would I get
done if I wasn't stopping to look at a
piece of ass in the distance you know or
if I didn't catch a whiff of some trim
you know coming around the corner on a
windy day you know that stopped me and
made me go look and lurking you know
there's something about there's
something about you having penis and
nuts that makes that slows a man down I
find I really do there are days I kid
you not where I want to I have my penis
and nuts taken off and have them sent to
on us out sent them into a country of
starving country because that's that's a
week and a half a meet right there to be
honest and some of yous like that sounds
dirty that's not dirty it's not dirty
when you're starving and some dude shows
up with you know a decent piece of meat
and some you know nut nuts or meat in
some places when you're poor dude nuts
or meat you know you want some almonds
how do you want a medium-rare nuts or
meat in some countries so you know their
tongues I've thought about that but
everybody wants to do that go hard it
can chop the junk off that way those
booty goings that they do bring that
behind over they're not going to be able
to wrap it around nothing and second of
all he could just drink water and have
his own behold sewn up or put up I don't
know what kind of stopper you get or
something I'm sure there's someone with
some of these pornography websites you
know but I would definitely get him saw
shank redemption haven't watch that
before he goes in you know maybe haven't
get a tattoo above his above his be
above his bababa that says Brooks was
here you know let him know that you know
they've already got somebody that's uh
swinging from this rope if you feel me
you know they already got somebody up in
this say Watson a hole so that's just a
little bit of advice man or just some
guidance but I want to thank all the
callers man and and everybody else hit
the hotline we got a few more calls that
came in I might be able to get to them
today but I want to thank everybody that
came out in
we'll continue to support please if you
can go get that 30 pound bag a hamster
bones my boy Joe Rogan just added a new
show
let me see where's he at I want to say
Minnesota I'm just checking on my
Twitter but you can check out Theo von
calm slash store and grab some different
things you can check out the of uncommon
last tour
grab some tickets I want to do a show in
Vancouver in August but I got to find a
small place where I could do a show you
know a place that holds about a hundred
I think is what I'd be looking for
because I've never been to that market
so that would be something but thirty
pound bag of hamster bones is available
on iTunes and you can also get musket
fire the early years and that's edgier
material but it's out there for you
Sacramento Rogan decided another show in
Sacramento and Coco
where's Coco at dude I don't even know
man I'm mad flavored there's only put up
of a video game ahem today that was
pretty funny online anyhow he was in
Vegas this weekend so I'm gonna where
he's at next weekend rod share that with
you but it looks like you had a good
time I want to thank you guys again for
the support thank you for watching this
past weekend tell your friends hit the
hotline you got something you want to
talk about you want to share on
something we've already talked about
feel free man beware of those bootie
goons dude or if you're going to go into
prison maybe goon up you know what I'm
saying be a BG yourself you know
sometimes the first step to not getting
pummeled is to is to pummel is to pummel
out of the gate so if we had any loose
ends we'll try to follow up on them you
guys subscribe on the YouTube and on the
iTunes I'll see in Orlando this week
thank you for watching this past weekend
I'm going to take us out again with some
spencer jacob growl and this is
celebrate
be good to yourselves man
oh yeah if you look on YouTube right now
somebody brought me a hamster in a
little wheel as a gift beautiful thank
you celebrate
[Music]
the diamond let's repeat it
the heart's full man that's my dog I'm
trying to definitely Oh
you know it's tough sometimes who did
not get their rat bags died you're so
tempted to think there's so much trash
out there I mean it just does not feel
the sex that drugs the rock'n'roll
disorientation looming like never before
on us men like never before and women
and I want to talk about women out there
throwing that hand you got if you want
to hit the hotline about that women are
throwing that hang around that's
different than when I was young you know
when I was young it was different it was
just yet the bars were closed you see
women out there looking for they peek
you know looking for a low you know
trying to catch a hit off that tall
glacier you know what I'm saying
time to change my fame it's wrong but it
is different than petty with death be
good to yourselves man I'm trying I'll
be out there with you man but head up to
the Comedy Store and give me a set in
man y'all be good
take care